Озброєні до зубів нацгвардійці виходять на патрулювання українських міст.
Такими панічними повідомленнями вибухнули соцмережі після того,
як міністр МВС видав наказ вивести Нацгвардію на допомогу поліції.
У мене є засіб зв’язку, газ сльозогіної дії "Кобра", палка  гумова
"Форт 12 М" - засіб для відстрілу гумових куль, травматична зброя.
І жодної вогнепальної зброї.
Таке екіпірування дозволено кожному нацгвардійцю, який патрулює українські міста.
І воно не відрізняється від оснащення поліцейських.
Старший солдат строкової служби Нацгвардії Євген Татулов
дивується негативній реакції громадян і розповідає:
вони вже давно займаються патрулювання міст.
Просто раніше головним в групі був поліцейський, тепер же гвардійці ходять самі.
Різниця в тому, що якщо на маршруті щось трапляється,
ми доповідаємо черговому в військовому наряді - нашому старшому.
Він вже приїжджає , в нього є камера, яка фіксує всі дії.
Нацгвардійці - так само як і поліцейські - мають право перевіряти документи,
опитувати людей, зупиняти транспорт, обмежувати пересування людей і машин,
можуть проникати у житло. Патрулі зі службовими собаками Нацгвардії,
так само, як і їхні колеги з поліції,
також можуть патрулювати вулиці та зупиняти людей,
наприклад, за підозрою у поширенні наркотиків.
І просто повинні реагувати, якщо хтось загрожує, наприклад, безпеці громадян.
Звичайно ж - після попередження.
Всі дії гвардійців, каже начальник військової частини № 3030 Віталій Танько,
мають відповідати статям закону про Національну поліцію та закону
про патрульну поліцію, але все ж їм дозволяється не все.
У випадку скоєння злочину ми діємо тільки спільно
з працівниками патрульної поліції, або викликаємо слідчо-оперативну групу.
Ми самостійно не діємо, не затримуємо, не доставляємо.
Це проводять працівники поліції.
Ми не можемо замінити їх, бо в нас різні,
ну не різні, а в нас менше прав.
Проте правозахисники заявляють, що все ж мають підстави перейматися тим,
чи не порушують базові права людини патрулі гвардійців.
Юрист Михайло Каменєв вважає, що наказ про залучення військовослужбовців
до охорони громадського порядку суперечить Конституції.
Частина 4 ст. 17 Конституції каже,
що ніхто не може використати збройні формування
для обмеження прав та свобод громадян. Обмеження, не обов’язково порушення.
Порушення -це вже коли щось неправильно зроблено.
Поліція обмежує права громадян постійно, в основному, на законних підставах.
А Нацгвардія не може обмежувати права.
Керівництво Нацгвардії заявляє, що різниці між поліцейським та військовослужбовцем немає,
а патрулі керуватимуться одними й тими ж законами.
Проте з точки зору «Правозахисної ініціативи», різниця все ж є.
Хоча і Нацгвардія, і Нацполіція підпорядковуються міністерству внутрішніх справ,
але поліцейський може відмовитися виконувати наказ, а гвардієць - ні.
Через 5 років після насилля на Майдані
страх, що військовослужбовці можуть спрямувати зброю проти цивільних – досі великий.
Якщо у поліцейського забезпечується це дисциплінарною відповідальністю,
і найгірше, що його очікує за відмову виконати наказ - це звільнення з поліції,
то для військовослужбовця це вже кримінально каране діяння
і доволі суворе може бути покарання за невиконання наказу.
Тож, військослужбовці набагато менше думатимуть
виконувати чи не виконувати наказ.
Я не кажу, що вони бездумно будуть це робити, але будуть менше думати над цим.
Педагог за освітою та молода мати Ірина Бойко
в лавах Нацгвардії вже кілька місяців. Вона служить за контрактом на посаді стрільчині.
Це ії третє чергування в київському житловому кварталі біля станції метро Нивки.
Жінка каже – вона шокована тим, наскільки цей район неспокійний.
Дуже багато людей, які гуляють з собаками в нетверезому вигляді,
собаки без намордників. Тобто люди
можуть спускати цю собаку на людей....
деякі хамлять, не звертають увагу на те, що гуляють діти малі.
Навіть водії за кермом автомобілю не дуже уважні дорогах.
Дуже багато правопорушень.
Ірина, як і решта її колег, знає, що патрульній поліції не вистачає кадрів.
Лише за офіційними даними наразі недобір на рівні 20% персоналу.
Ситуація ускладнює те, що нині літо, коли частина поліцейських у відпустках.
Тож, як каже жінка, люди мають бачити на вулицях правоохоронців:
хоча б для того, щоб не забувати про елементарні правила поведінки та дотримання закону.
Як-от в цьому випадку.
Чоловіки побачили нацгвардійців
та швиденько побігли зі своїми пляшками в під’їзд.
А ці одразу повикидали пляшки в смітники.
Ірина вважає, що в таких районах повноважень і прав Нацгвардії не вистачить,
щоб швидко вирішити ці проблеми.
Потрібна кропітка робота усіх правоохоронних структур.
А правозахисник Михайло Каменєв додає – необхідні ще й серйозні зміни
в законодавстві та роз’яснення Конституційного суду:
чи може Нацгвардія і далі брати участь в патрулюваннях українських міст.
Наказ МВС про залучення майже шестисот патрулів гвардійців
по всій Україні діє до особливого розпорядження і поки має тимчасовий характер.